Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a family comedy
film called “Thunderpants”.
Watch out and take care!
In the opening scene, the Smash family is
in a hospital room, waiting to welcome the
new member of their family.
Mrs. Smash struggles to give birth but after
a strong push, the baby flies out of her.
It does several flips mid-air and has a full
head of hair.
Thankfully, the doctor catches him and hands
him back to the family.
They name the baby boy, Patrick.
While trying to take a family picture, Patrick
farts for the first time.
Following that, it never stops.
The parents can hardly sleep at night because
of the fart noises.
Patrick’s strange condition would have been
tolerable to his parents if it weren’t for
the foul smell.
One time, Mr. Smash goes to tend the infant
in the middle of the night and has to retreat
because of the pungent smell.
Patrick won’t sleep the entire night and
only keeps passing gas.
When it is time for a change, Mr. Smash comes
up with an innovative idea.
He ties a plastic garbage bag around Patrick’s
waist so the noise would be suppressed and
the smell wouldn’t spread around the room.
However, the bag gets so big that it explodes
with a loud bang waking the entire neighborhood.
As Patrick grows up into a toddler, Mr. Smash
gets more creative.
He attaches Patrick’s behind to one end
of a pipe, that way his farts are transported
outside.
But the kid moves so much that the pipe detaches
from the other end.
One time, the pipe lands right before Mr.
Smash’s face, and the fart hospitalizes
him.
Following the event, he keeps himself busy
with work and hardly ever stays at home.
Until eventually, he abandons the family and
leaves them forever.
Patrick’s older sister Denise starts hating
him for destroying her perfect little family.
Even Mrs. Smash blames him for the trouble.
Patrick is nervous and excited for his first
day of school.
He tries to fit in like everyone else but
he has to let out a fart only a few minutes
in.
The kids retreat away from him and laugh.
Except a boy named Alan who is kind to Patrick.
Alan has a condition called Anosmia and thus
lacks the sense of smell.
The two become best friends and do everything
together.
Patrick’s life doesn't get easier even after
getting a friend.
He is constantly bullied by a guy named Damon
at his school.
During the morning assembly, the kids are
asked to keep quiet for a special guest’s
speech.
Everyone does as told but Patrick lets out
a loud and pungent fart which gets him suspended
for a few days.
Patrick wants to become an astronaut when
he grows up but he doesn’t know if that
is possible because of his problem.
He frequently watches shows about space and
astronomy and is left disheartened when his
favorite astronaut says that an astronaut
should have complete control of himself.
Alan, on the other hand, wants to be a scientist
and invent a flying machine that doesn’t
use fuel.
Patrick asks for his help to create a device
that will suppress his farts.
Alan takes on the challenge and spends hours
in his backyard lab to create a fart collecting
and suppressing device called the thunderpants.
While Patrick is waiting for his friend outside
the lab, someone takes a picture of him without
him knowing.
After getting done, Alan makes Patrick wear
the device that collects his fats in a box
with the press of a button.
Following that, the box is supposed to be
kept in a stabilizer that suppresses the fart
smell and disposes of it.
Patrick is beyond thankful to his friend now
that he has solved the biggest problem in
his life.
Before this, he was only allowed to eat whole
grain food, so, he walks up to her sister
and eats a spoonful of beans from her plate.
Denise is left speechless because she is used
to mocking him for not being able to eat tasty
food like her.
The following day at school, everyone is asked
to stay silent in the morning assembly.
The thunderpants work and no one hears Patrick
farting.
During the lunch break, he asks Alan to help
him find his “unique talent” because his
favorite astronaut Gen. Ed Sheppard said on
a TV show that all the astronauts have one.
Alan bluntly tells his friend that he has
no unique talent, completely overlooking his
ability to fart.
As they talk, the bully Damon asks for Patrick’s
lunch box and snatches his fart collecting
box instead.
When he opens it, he is blasted with a pungent
smell and a green powder on his face.
He gets so mad at Patrick for setting up the
prank that he ties him to the monkey bar as
a punishment.
The bully and his friends tear open the thunderpants
and beat him up.
They have to retreat when he lets out a smelly
fart yet again.
Everyone calls him a fartboy and makes fun
of him while poor Patrick stands humiliated.
The next day, he doesn’t go to school, still
traumatized by the event.
In the evening, Alan comes to visit him with
a better thunderpant to replace the one that
was destroyed.
However, Patrick has lost the will to suppress
his farts because his dream to become an astronaut
isn’t going to come true anyway.
Alan realistically tells him that to become
an astronaut one should be at his physical
peak and has to pass several exams.
Patrick is far from healthy and is not smart
enough to pass them.
Alan apologizes for being so blunt but Patrick
walks away, knowing that he is telling the
truth.
When Alan returns home, two men outside Patrick’s
house keep an eye on him.
We see that they have several pictures of
both Alan and Patrick, almost as if they have
been spying on them.
That week, Ms. Smash brings Patrick to the
hospital to get his condition checked professionally.
The doctor is shocked to see that the kid
has two stomachs.
He calls Patrick medical magic but also calls
his ability, a completely useless gift.
Patrick is overjoyed because having two stomachs
means he has a unique quality, which he thinks
makes him eligible to become an astronaut.
Meanwhile, Alan is planning to participate
in an invention competition where he has to
create a vehicle that will fly a hundred meters
without using fuel.
After finding out that his friend has two
stomachs, he plans to use Patrick’s farting
abilities to win the competition.
On the day of the said competition, they go
against many participants but none of their
devices are able to move to the threshold
distance.
Some devices fall apart while others do not
start at all.
When it is Alan’s turn, they use Patrick’s
farts to make a device fly in the air.
The audience is left stunned in the first
half.
But soon, the device malfunctions, and the
fart is blown towards them.
Alan quickly repairs it and wins the competition.
Following the win, Patrick gets enough courage
to stand up to Damon.
He follows him to a forest and farts in his
face, making him fall unconscious.
As Patrick is smugly returning home that day,
he sees Alan get into a black car with a suitcase.
On inquiring to Alan’s father about his
whereabouts, he is given a letter.
In it, Alan wishes him luck for his dream
and says that he will be out for long.
His father claims he has moved to a different
country and won’t be back soon.
Without his best friend, Patrick doesn’t
know what to do.
He returns home and watches the news about
a group of astronauts being stranded in space.
Astronaut Ed Sheppard says that the team needs
a miracle to be brought back to the earth
safely.
Later, the opera singer Sir John Osgood approaches
Patrick to help him in his next performance.
John had seen Patrick in the competition and
believes that his fart has the perfect pitch
that he needs at the end of his song.
When John promises to take him to a different
country, Patrick agrees to go, hoping that
he would find his best friend.
First, they travel to Paris and perform in
front of an audience consisting of world-famous
opera singers.
At the end of the song, Patrick farts, helping
John reach a perfect pitch.
John gets a standing ovation from the audience
who are unaware that Patrick was helping him.
Following the show, John is noted as the best
opera singer in the work, much to his competitor,
Placido P. Placeedo’s annoyance.
John and Patrick travel all over Europe singing
in various shows.
With every show, John’s popularity increases.
However, he urges Patrick to practice farting
every day for hours, letting him eat only
after he hits the correct notes.
One day, while he is practicing, he is visited
by Placido who finds out about John’s little
secret.
He then mixes a laxative on a pie and feeds
it to Patrick, hoping to ruin John’s next
performance.
A few hours later, John is singing in one
of his shows.
As usual, Patrick hits the highest notes with
his farts and even breaks wine glasses with
the noise.
The spotlight right above the stage dangles
dangerously because of the noise.
The laxative works and Patrick’s fart turns
pungent and loses its pitch.
An embarrassed John stands humiliated as the
audience laughs.
Moments later, Placido gets on the stage and
drags Patrick in front of everyone revealing
John’s secret.
Just then, the spotlight falls on him, killing
him instantly.
Both John and Patrick are convinced of murder
since the falling of the spotlight was their
fault.
Several people testify against the poor kid,
saying that he has always been cruel.
Damon accuses him of trying to kill him with
his fart.
When the reporters ask Patrick about his thoughts
on the situation, he claims that he was with
John to look for his best friend and didn’t
know Placido was going to die.
Alan, from another country, sees Patrick on
TV and asks him to be brought to the country
as well.
Back in the court, Patrick is proven guilty
of all charges and is given the death penalty.
Right when he is about to be shot, a miracle
happens.
A US special agent comes to save him and legally
brings him to their headquarters.
He is also the same person who had been spying
on Alan and Patrick for a long time.
Patrick is flown to America in a private jet.
On landing, he reunites with Alan who claims
that he was contacted by astronaut Ed Sheppard.
The astronaut recognized him as a genius kid
and recruited him to save the ones who are
stranded in space.
Since it was supposed to be a secret, Alan
couldn’t tell Patrick before leaving.
He apologizes for being a bad friend and the
two reconcile.
Patrick is also told that only he, who has
two stomachs can save the stranded astronauts
in space.
He is beyond happy to finally get to be a
“spaceman”.
They meet Ed Sheppard who welcomes Patrick
to their team.
Following that, Alan introduces Patrick to
his team of little scientists recruited from
around the world.
They inform him of a device they have created
that will gather the energy from his farts
and multiply it.
Using the technique, Patrick will thus have
to launch the rescue rocket to space.
Starting that day, he is trained to become
an astronaut.
The officials are worried because he has failed
all mental and physical tests that an astronaut
should pass.
However, Ed Sheppard is confident that the
kid will rescue the stranded team.
After a week of training, Patrick is put in
a spacesuit, ready for the mission.
The entire world watches in awe as the kid
boards the rocket.
However, Alan is informed that there is a
seventy percent chance that the rocket will
blow up shortly after the liftoff.
He tells his friend of the possibilities but
Patrick doesn’t back down.
On a count of ten, He lets out a fart and
the rocket lifts off the station.
Everyone in the control room cheers for the
kid but soon, they lose all communication.
As they start to lose hope, the communication
turns back on, and Patrick finally reaches
space.
In the following scene, we see him bring down
the stranded astronauts.
He is welcomed with loud cheers and praised
by everyone in the world.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank You for watching.